nos dicen que lorena se fue a un viaje
de senderismo de cuatro días cada día
caminaba un 20% más que la distancia que
caminó el día anterior recorrió un total
de 27 kilómetros cuál es la distancia
que camino lorena en el primer día del
viaje y dice redondea tu respuesta final
al kilómetro más cercano como siempre
trata de calcular cuánto camino el
primer día muy bien llamemos a la
cantidad que camino el primer día y
luego usando a veamos si podemos
escribir una expresión para calcular
cuánto camino en total de modo que eso
debería ser igual a 27 y luego tal vez
podríamos calcular a así que el primer
día ella camino a kilómetros ahora
cuánto camino el segundo día bueno nos
dicen que cada día ella camino un 20%
más que la distancia que camino el día
anterior entonces el día siguiente ella
camino 20% más que a así que eso es
igual a 1.2 por a
y cuanto camino después en su tercer día
bueno eso es igual a 1.2 por el segundo
día y es 1.2 por 1.2 o podemos decir 1.2
al cuadrado por a y luego cuánto camino
en el cuarto día ella hizo un viaje de
senderismo de 4 días así que ese es el
último día bueno eso será 1.2 por el
tercer día por lo tanto esto va a ser
igual a 1.2 a la tercera potencia por a
entonces esta es una expresión de app
para calcular lo que ella caminó durante
los 4 días y sabemos que ella camino un
total de 27 kilómetros por lo que esto
es igual a 27 kilómetros ahora podrías
calcular en esta expresión
podrías factorizar la y decir a por uno
más 1.2 más 1.2 al cuadrado más 1.2 a la
tercera potencia es igual a 27 y luego
podrías decir que a es igual a 27 sobre
1.2 más 1.2 al cuadrado más 1.2 a la
tercera potencia y necesitaríamos una
calculadora para evaluar esto pero voy a
hacer una técnica diferente una técnica
que funcionaría incluso si tuvieras 20
términos aquí en teoría también podrías
hacer esto con 20 términos pero se
vuelve mucho más complicado también
podrías si tuvieras 200 términos
entonces la otra forma de abordar esto
es usar la fórmula para una serie
geométrica finita como lo vamos a
evaluar y solo como recordatorio la suma
de los primeros n términos va a ser el
primer término que podríamos llamar a
menos el primer término multiplicado por
nuestra proporción común en este caso
nuestra proporción común es 1.2 porque
cada término sucesivo es 1.2 por el
primero por lo tanto nuestro primer
término multiplica nuestra proporción
común a la enésima potencia todo esto
sobre uno menos la proporción común
en otros vídeos explicamos de dónde
viene esto lo demostramos pero aquí
podemos aplicarlo ya sabemos cuál es
nuestra a la usamos como nuestra
variable nuestra proporción común en
esta situación es igual a 1.2 y nuestra
n va a ser igual a 4 otra forma en que
me gusta pensarlo es nuestro primer
término que vemos justo allí menos el
término el que no llegamos si tuviéramos
un quinto término estaríamos restando
ese quinto término porque no estamos
llegando a la cuarta potencia aquí el
quinto término habría sido a la cuarta
potencia todo eso sobre uno menos la
proporción común y así el lado izquierdo
de nuestra ecuación la podríamos
describir como nuestro primer término
menos nuestro primer término
multiplicado por nuestra proporción
común 1.2 a la cuarta potencia y todo
eso sobre uno menos nuestra proporción
común y entonces eso podría ser igual a
27 permítanme desplazarme un poco hacia
abajo para tener más espacio para
resolver
veamos si puedo simplificar esto un poco
esto va a ser igual a menos 0.2 en el
numerador podemos factorizar de modo que
esto será igual aa por 1 menos 1.2 a la
cuarta potencia podemos multiplicar
tanto el numerador como el denominador
por menos 1 y esto nos llevará a a x voy
a poner a afuera de la fracción así que
cambiar el orden aquí y me voy a
deshacer de este negativo 1.2 a la
cuarta potencia menos uno sobre 0.2 es
igual a 27 una vez más todo lo que hice
fue sacar a la de la fracción así que
está aquí y multiplique el numerador y
el denominador por menos 1 el numerador
x menos 1 cambia a estos dos y luego
multiplicar menos 0.2 por menos 1 es
igual a 0.2 positivo ahora sólo puedo
multiplicar ambos lados por el recíproco
de esto entonces lo haré aquí arriba 0.2
sobre 1.2 a la cuarta
a menos uno y luego aquí 0.2 sobre 1.2 a
la cuarta potencia menos 1 esto se
cancela con esto esto se cancela con
esto es por eso exactamente que lo hice
y nos quedamos con una es igual a 27 por
0.2 todo eso sobre 1.2 a la cuarta
potencia menos 1 y esta expresión
debería darnos exactamente el mismo
valor que la expresión que acabamos de
ver pero esta expresión es útil incluso
si tuviéramos y en términos podríamos
usar la sacaré la calculadora en
realidad evaluar el primero este
denominador
1.2 a la cuarta potencia es igual a
menos 1 es igual a y esto está en el
denominador por lo que simplemente
podría tomar el recíproco y luego
multiplicar eso por 27 por 0.2
es igual a 5.0 29 ahora quieren que
redondeamos nuestra respuesta al
kilómetro más cercano por lo que esto
será aproximadamente igual a 5
kilómetros esto es aproximadamente lo
que habría viajado el primer día de su
viaje de senderismo